Westworld Season 2 Episode 5 begins in the
week ahead timeline.
Strand’s forces are “draining” the flooded
valley, and fishing out the dead hosts – bringing
them to the Mesa Hub to try’n fix them and
recover their code.
But Antoine finds that a third of the host
brains are empty.
Not like they’re “wiped”, but “Like
they never held data to begin with” . So
did someone put new empty brains in these
hosts?
What happened to their old brains?
Maybe these empty hosts are decoys, and Dolores
put their real brains in new bodies, so they
can escape Westworld – like how Maeve got
a new body to remove the explosive in her
spine last season . Dolores said she’d use
the valley as “a weapon” , so maybe these
hosts in the valley are part of her plan.
We also see more of the Cradle – a kind
of “simulation technology” or “time
capsule”.
Someone has destroyed the “hosts' backups”
it held . If the hosts no longer have backups,
maybe it’s now possible for them to permanently
die – and like William they’re in real
danger for the first time .
Strand makes a weird comment about someone
giving “quite a story” . He might mean
Ford’s story.
At least some of what’s happening this season
seems to be part of Ford’s last narrative
– he said there’d be “violence” and
“Surprises” and “the birth of a new
people” . Both Bernard and William say they’re
in Ford’s “game” . But Strand looks
at Bernard and talks about figuring out “how
the story turns” . Like in Episode 1, it
seems like Strand is trying to get information
out of Bernard . What does he think Bernard
knows?
Something about Peter Abernathy, or James
Delos?
Or Ford, and the general Skynet shitstorm?
Does Strand know that Bernard is a host?
Bernie is acting weird.
There are theories that this Bernard is actually
a human-host clone of Arnold , or that this
whole week-ahead timeline is a simulation
in the Cradle to interrogate Bernard.
At this point we still don’t know, but something
is up here.
In the previous week timeline, Teddy and Dolores
arrive at Sweetwater.
Teddy calls this place “home” , because
he and Dolores lived here for thirty years.
But Dolores says it’s not really home . They
see Clementine meeting the new host that took
over her role after Clem was decommissioned
– she says the same scripted lines that
Clem said in her loop.
So this is proof of the fakeness of life in
Sweetwater . And if their lives were fake,
is Dolores and Teddy’s relationship real?
They go to a field where they used to dream
of running away together “Someday” . But
after thirty years in their loops, “Someday”
never came.
Now that they’re “free”, Teddy asks
Dolores to finally go start a life together
. But Dolores feels she has to stay and fight
her war against humans . In a way, her wokeness
makes her less free – she feels more responsibility
now than she did as an ignorant machine.
But Dolores does decide that her love for
Teddy is real , and they have sex, maybe for
the first time in their thirty year relationship.
But it might also be their last time.
Dolores has a weird metaphor about burning
weak cows to stop a spreading sickness . The
point is she thinks Teddy is too nice to survive
the war ahead . Like, in Episode 3, Teddy
let Craddock go free – then Craddock went
on a killing spree in Las Mudas.
Teddy’s mercy is dangerous.
And with this sickness metaphor, it sounds
like Dolores is worried that Teddy’s compassion
might spread.
So Dolores uses her human tech, Phil, to “Overwrite”
Teddy’s personality.
The changes are so “extreme” that Phil
says Teddy might not survive . These shots
from a pre-release of the episode show Teddy’s
personality before and after – Dolores maxes
out his aggression and cruelty, and sets his
empathy to zero.
These shots might not be canon, but the point
is Dolores destroys the man Teddy was – she
sacrifices the one she loves for the sake
of her war, like Stannis with Shireen.
As Maeve argued earlier, it seems hypocritical
for Dolores to kill and control people when
she claims to be fighting for freedom . Dolores
says this is the only way , and that she knows
“how this story ends” . So maybe she’s
got some master plan, with the Valley and
these hosts – and the death of Teddy.
But even if this wins her war, is it worth
her becoming like the enemy she’s fighting
against?
Dolores prepares the Westworld train to go
to the Mesa Hub and rescue her host father
Peter , who was taken by Charlotte in Episode
3.
After Dolores’ brutality towards Teddy,
you gotta wonder if Dolores is helping Peter
out of love, or if she just needs the data
in his head for her plan.
Maeve and co.
get captured by samurai hosts from Shogunworld.
Maeve uses her voice commands on them, but
they don’t work cause the Shogun hosts only
know Japanese . That would also explain why
these Ghost Nation hosts were immune earlier
– they speak Lakota.
But Lee says that all hosts have many languages
buried in their code – which’ll come in
handy later on.
Lee says Shogunworld is like Westworld, but
more violent, and Japanese , so rich weebs
can wave katanas around.
Which doesn’t seem very safe – Westworld’s
guns are one thing, but it must be hard to
stop guests hurting themselves with swords
and things.
We learn that Lee copied bits of Shogunworld
off Westworld . So there’s a town like Sweetwater,
with a place like the Mariposa Saloon.
The hosts Akane and Sakura are based on Maeve
and Clementine.
And the hosts Musashi and Hanaryo rob Akane’s
tea house, just like Hector and Armistice
robbed Maeve’s saloon.
Lots of these shots are direct recreations
of the Westworld originals.
So this is a classic Westworld brainfuck,
using repetition to make us question identity
– what does it mean to be Maeve when there’s
a Japanese copy of her?
It also reflects the long history of Japanese
samurai films and Westerns borrowing from
each other . Musashi’s actor says it’s
“beautiful” the way East and West used
each other’s ideas . And yet HBO keeps restricting
our videos for copyright, so go figure.
The Westworld hosts have mixed reactions to
their “doppel-bot[s]”.
Hector doesn’t trust Musashi.
Armistice and Hanaryo snake-charm each other.
And Maeve sees herself in Akane.
Akane’s motherly relationship with Sakura
is similar to Maeve’s relationships with
Clementine and with her daughter.
So when Akane kills to protect Sakura from
the Shogun’s men, Maeve decides to help
her.
That night, the group is attacked by the Shogun’s
ninjas, who abduct Sakura.
Maeve has visions and hears voices – she
seems to be tapping in to the “mesh network”
Bernard mentioned – a subconscious link
between nearby hosts . It’s like Maeve is
psychic and can hack hosts with her mind.
So she uses this “voice” power to control
and kill a ninja . When the Shogun’s army
arrives, Hector Musashi Armistice and Hanaryo
make a distraction so Maeve and Akane can
escape – turns out Maeve wasn’t kidding
about leaving Hector for dead . Lee questions
whether Maeve should risk herself to help
Akane and Sakura, arguing that they’re just
machines . But Maeve says her choices and
love are more than just code . On the way
to save Sakura, we see Delos security have
been slaughtered by Shogunworld hosts . Which
is… impressive.
Like, the battle of Fort Forlorn Hope was
one thing – those hosts had guns and nitro.
But the Shogun hosts have swords – and somehow
they beat Delos security who have assault
rifles . They also have walkie talkie thingies
– Lee takes one from a corpse.
Maybe he’s planning to betray Maeve, and
rejoin the humans.
Maeve and co.
pretend to be a Chinese envoy, and go meet
the Shogun.
The Shogun’s off his loop, but not cause
he’s woke – he’s just “broken”,
leaking brain fluid like Bernard was . Akane
shows herself to the Shogun, who is shocked
that she’d risk her life for Sakura instead
of running away . It’s just like how Maeve
risks her life to rescue her daughter instead
of leaving Westworld last season.
The Shogun agrees to release Sakura, if Akane
dances for him.
That night, Maeve and Akane find the Shogun
has carved the shape of “A cherry blossom
tree” into Sakura’s back.
The name Sakura means cherry blossom in Japanese
. Akane and Maeve talk about their shared
scripted story of a “new world” which
represents freedom to them . Maeve uses her
voice power and offers to wake Akane, show
her the truth behind her simulated world.
But Akane refuses – and Maeve respects her
choice, so Akane can keep her grief for Sakura’s
pain . Which kind of implies that love and
grief are illusions that Akane might lose
if she awoke.
But the way Maeve lets Akane choose contrasts
with Dolores forcing Teddy to her will.
Though these might both be paths to consciousness
– a big theme of last season is that suffering
leads hosts to awakening . Dolores makes Teddy
suffer, and says “we all need to suffer”
“To grow” . And Maeve lets Akane choose
to feel Sakura’s pain.
These two different paths might reflect how
Maeve and Dolores themselves first became
conscious – Maeve chose to get off that
train.
But Dolores’ awakening with Ford was suspiciously
similar to her coded killing of Arnold.
Is Dolores really free?
The stage is set for Akane’s dance.
In the background, these banners show symbols
of Westworld, the maze and the Delos data
project – cause the best way to hide a conspiracy
is to show its symbol everywhere.
The Shogan kills Sakura – to the horror
of Akane and Maeve.
Of course, they could probably resurrect Sakura,
like Dolores raised Craddock – but maybe
Sakura’s death is more meaningful if it’s
final.
In Episode 1, Arnold said that something’s
real when it’s “irreplaceable” . Akane
performs her dance, and ends it by ripping
off the Shogun’s head – kind of like in
Zoolander.
The title of this episode is “Akane no Mai”,
which can mean Akane’s dance.
But Akane also means deep red . And this is
a bloody red dance.
Just before the Shogun’s men kill Maeve,
she unlocks her mutant power and reaches into
the Matrix and makes all of the Shogun’s
men kill each other.
With her new power, Maeve can control all
hosts.
She says she “found a new voice”, and
“Now we use it” . And then she picks up
a sword.
But maybe Maeve will use her power for something
more than killing.
Before, we saw Maeve use her voice power to
lead Akane towards consciousness.
Maeve’s power can wake hosts.
And the way Bernard described the mesh network,
a message can be sent to nearby hosts, who
spread the message to yet more hosts – if
Maeve’s voice works through this network,
maybe Maeve could chain wake hundreds of hosts
at once.
So Westworld continues to ask complex questions
about freedom and control, consciousness and
identity.
Who what and when is Bernard?
Is Ford still in control?
What’s happening at the valley?
Is it okay for Dolores to control hosts?
Are Dolores and Teddy’s lives real?
What does it mean to be you if there are two
yous?
And what’s the right way use a magic wifi
superpower?
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video, please like and
subscribe and consider supporting Alt Shift
X on Patreon.
You can get behind-the-scenes stuff on the
Discord, topic votes, scripts, streams and
more.
Thanks to Patrons Bret M Benack, Mike Valdellon,
Scott Seligman, Ashley Carter, Kajetan Janiak,
Sable Lion, Kendra Henry, Anne Fiske, Rayan
Chibani, and Honeycomb.
Cheers.